Fredrickson has become one of Berlin's
trendy districts it draws tourists
partiers artists of every ilk lots of
students and independent thinkers
it's also begun attracting companies 13
years ago Universal Music moved its
German headquarters from Hamburg to
Berlin Friedrich sign into an old
warehouse on the banks of the spray with
500 employees Berlin is extremely
liberal relatively affordable and
multicultural promotes creativity which
is what we need in a creative business
dealing with a creative product that's
the atmosphere we want to breathe we
want to be where the creativity is where
artists feel more comfortable where they
live we want to be part of this scene
visiting musicians partiers and tourists
can stay at the design hotel now one of
a spanish-based chain it opened here in
November 2010 rooms start at 115 euros a
night electric guitars are available in
the music studio on the top floor the
hotel is almost always booked out quite
a few individual tourists come over the
weekend or during the holidays but in
terms of business clientele we also have
lots of companies booking and we host
lots of major events we have enormous
space for conferences and programmes you
can tell the companies want to come to
Berlin and need locations here of course
prices have risen along with the
district's popularity rents had been
going up since the Berlin Wall came down
but faster than the average for other
major cities
axl Mishka grew up in Friedreich's Heim
and opened a shop here in 1990 he's glad
to have the big spending customers but
he knows many original residents can
hardly afford to live here anymore you
can't just think of business you also
have to consider the residents and here
I see a negative tendency converting
living space to condominiums can be good
but not when only a select few can
afford it it's not so great and it
pushes everybody else to the outskirts
um go so far as to condemn the
development of the spray embankment as a
death blow to the district so says
graphic designer Roberto moshansky he's
in a citizen's initiative dedicated to
stopping the construction of new
high-rises and the consequences that
might have will end up with traffic
congestion much like in Paris my cars
are always caught in those traffic
circles everybody honking and nobody
moving we're afraid we'll see that here
plus too many condominiums are being put
up just because their investments are
even money laundering schemes of course
we're against that Berlin's popularity
keeps growing
another symptomatic phenomenon is the mo
billion scout company a major European
real estate portal for referring
apartments and houses for rent or sale
the personnel manager keeps hiring new
people with the housing market booming
the company is flourishing
I think Friedrich sign is a bit more
expensive but it's also highly sought
after that has an impact well by viewer
active all across Germany and Berlin -
of course
Berlin is incredibly important for our
market but this is the trend all across
Germany because I'm Deutsche danza in
2014 almost 12 million tourists came to
Berlin and they go where the action is
these two students are from London and
they're here to party and they can do
just that right near their hotel in The
Happening district of berlin friedrich
sign